the foreign secretary liz truss is with
us i know you're incredibly busy so we
really appreciate you taking the time
thank you
quick thoughts on uh things like the
fact that we've heard words like
imminent and likely regarding
an invasion where are we this tuesday
morning as far as you're concerned well
it's still the case that an invasion
could be imminent
and it is highly likely what we are
doing is pursuing the path of deterrence
and diplomacy urging vladimir putin to
step back from the brink he currently
has a hundred thousand troops stationed
on the ukrainian border we want those
troops to be moved but of course we are
preparing for the worst that's why we've
urged all british citizens to leave
ukraine and we're doing all we can to
support the ukrainian economy uh we
talked or rather we heard boris johnson
and president biden a 40-minute chat
yesterday on the phone talking about a
crucial window uh what do they mean by
that
well we know or we believe that vladimir
putin has not yet made a decision
about whether to invade ukraine we think
it's highly likely
there are huge numbers of troops lined
up on the border we know that they're in
a position to attack imminently but he
can still change his mind and that is
why diplomacy is so vital making it
clear to russia the cost that would be
of an invasion there would be severe
sanctions and we know the ukrainians
would fight back
we've helped train up 20 000 soldiers
we've provided defensive weapons and the
ukrainians will engage in what will be a
long drawn-out conflict which will be
hugely damaging for russia and the
people of russia
how quickly do we think that president
putin could take kiev if that's his plan
they're on on the northern border there
they're only about 140 miles north of
kiev
well we think an attack could be
imminent of course as i've said the
ukrainians will fight back so this could
lead to a very protracted conflict which
would be hugely damaging for russia but
in terms of the timing of an attack it
could be imminent which is why we're
advising all british citizens to leave
ukraine i understand whilst there is
still commercial routes open i
understand secretary my question is um
how quickly do we think that they could
move down to kiev if they didn't indeed
invade or very very quickly they they
have um
troops stationed around around ukraine
so there could be an attack on kiev uh
there could be an attack from the east
uh
and what we also suspect is there could
be a false flag operation
that there could be false claims that
that they have been provoked uh to give
a pretext uh for russian invasion and
what we have been doing is we've been
calling out the russians we've been
exposing uh their attempts to put a
puppet government into kiev we've been
exposing
their attempts to create a pretext but
what we do expect
over the next few days is there could be
an attempt
of a false flag operation to create a
pretext to claim the ukrainians are
attacking them so that the russians have
a justification
for invading ukraine is there any
evidence of that
there is evidence that that
that is the type of activity they're
looking at and we've seen the russians
do it before this is absolutely from the
russian playbook the use of cyber
attacks the attempts to undermine
the legitimacy of the ukrainian
government and the use of false flag
operations to justify a pretext for
invasion so those are the kinds of
things that we're looking out for
over the next day or so russian defense
minister says that's absolutely nonsense
and that many of the military drills
have already ended um and it looks as
though many of the troops will be moving
back from the borders within days we
can't take them at their word
well
why have they stationed a hundred
thousand troops on the ukrainian border
in a deliberately threatening fashion
and why is it the case that they have
the full supplies and preparations to be
able to mount an invasion and they
clearly are seeking to threaten ukraine
they're seeking to bully ukraine they've
been very clear that they have these
demands such as ukraine never being able
to join nato
such as moving ahead with the division
of parts of ukraine so it's very clear
that the russians have
some diplomatic aims which are
essentially reducing ukrainian
sovereignty and self-determination that
is why they've stationed those troops on
the border to seek to threaten nato and
threaten ukraine and that's why the only
thing i will believe kay is when they
move the troops away from the border
words are easy what they need to do is
move the troops away from the border do
we have any evidence that they've been
trying to end the crisis
well
they started the crisis first of all so
the only reason we are talking about
this today is because of russian
aggression everything nato has done has
been defensive we've been strengthening
the eastern flank because of the
increased aggression that we have seen
from russia and you know we have been
talking to russia i was in
moscow last week the prime minister has
spoken to president putin president
biden has spoken to putin so of course
we want a diplomatic solution but it
can't be at the expense of ukrainian
sovereignty the fact is that in 1994
russia signed up to the budapest
memorandum which agreed that in exchange
for giving up its nuclear weapons
ukraine would have sovereignty and
territorial integrity and russia are now
trying to undermine that but not any
diplomatic solution
has to respect the sovereignty of
ukraine but not to be members of nato uh
and as we know the ukrainians are very
keen to be members of nato uh which is
where the on pass
stands at the moment
ukraine is a sovereign country and it is
a decision for ukraine and nato
about whether or not
ukraine should be a member of nato it's
not a decision for russia russia should
not have a veto
over other countries security
arrangements and the big risk of course
if there is an invasion into ukraine uh
that would be hugely damaging for russia
and ukraine and it will further
undermine the stability of europe
president putin has
actively questioned why other countries
in eastern europe are members of nato as
well so this i fear would not stop at
ukraine this is an attack
on
the neighboring states of russia and
other east european countries and trying
to undermine the legitimacy of them
being part of nato but as you know
president putin's view is that nato
promised that it wouldn't move any
further east when we saw the breakup of
uh the soviet union there was no
agreement of that sort k there is no
agreement of that sort the agreements
i've talked about the budapest 1994
agreement uh the other agreements that
were signed as part of the osce the
security cooperation agreement
none of them mentioned that countries
could not be part of nato in fact
those agreements are very explicit that
countries should have responsibility for
their own security arrangements and they
should be free to make those
arrangements provided they don't
undermine other countries security and
the fact is
russia's security is not being
undermined nobody believes
that russia is under attack the issue
here is that russia is threatening
ukraine by stationing troops on its
border and you say potentially not stop
at ukraine what do you mean by that
what i mean is if we saw
an invasion into ukraine
there would be severe costs in terms of
a long-running conflict
we could see the undermining of security
more broadly in europe and we could also
see other aggressors around the world
see it as an opportunity
to
to expand their ambitions too so this is
a very dangerous moment for the world
this is of course about ukraine which is
an important sovereign nation but it's
also about the wider stability of europe
and it's about wider global stability
and the message that we give to
aggressors and we have to give the
message to vladimir putin that there can
be no reward for aggression there can be
no reward for lining up troops on
somebody else's border and threatening
to invade talk about other countries
which which countries were you talking
about
well i mean we are we're currently in
negotiations with iran
uh over stopping them acquiring a
nuclear weapon
in vienna uh we've seen
china uh increase its economic coercion
and flights over taiwan
we cannot give a message
that aggression gets rewards what are we
going to do about the british embassy
the u.s have temporarily relocated
theirs
we have moved some of our staff
to the west of ukraine
to levieve but we retain a presence in
kiev i'm going to continue with that we
are we are going to continue but of
course we are constantly looking at the
situation ukraine making sure that we
are providing a service for british
nationals at the same time as making
sure our staff are kept safe if
necessary how many uh ukrainian refugees
should we accept
well we're not uh we're not at that
point
at the moment what we are doing is we
are working on humanitarian response
with partners with non-government
organizations and with other countries
and our priority at the moment
is securing the return of british
nationals who want to return there are
some british nationals who want to stay
in ukraine we've made it very clear to
them what the risks are but our priority
is securing the return of british
nationals how difficult is it to
negotiate with the russians they weren't
particularly polite to you when you went
last week lavrov uh being incredibly
rude saying it was a conversation
between a dumb and a deaf person it
seems like we listen but don't hear what
would you say in response to him
well i made it very clear to minister
lavrov and i was also delivering a
message to the russian people that if
there was an invasion into ukraine there
would be severe costs to russia it would
result in a long-running conflict and it
would result in very tough sanctions
that would hit not just the oligarchs
close to putin but also major companies
in russia and of course sergey lavrov
didn't like what i had to say but i was
there in russia to deliver a message to
make it clear to the russian government
there wouldn't be rewards for aggression
and they need to move their troops away
from the border and the question that he
could not answer that sergey lavrov
could not answer is why there are a
hundred thousand troops on the russian
border with ukraine if they have no
plans to invade you very kindly came uh
to see us a couple of weeks ago uh when
you talked about nordstrom um two and
and when you were referring uh to that
you said uh that it completely stops if
there's an invasion we cannot favor
short-term economic interests over the
long-term survival of freedom and
democracy in europe are other germans
doing everything that they can as far as
well chancellor schultz is uh traveling
to moscow today
he's having a meeting with putin
when he was over in the united states
there was a press conference president
biden
made it very clear that nordstrom 2
would not go ahead and i hope that is
the message he is delivering to vladimir
putin today because it is simply
unconscionable
that that would go ahead in the event of
an
invasion of ukraine how worried are you
sitting here this morning i'm very
worried about the situation
we could be on the brink
of a war in europe which would have
severe consequences
not just for the people of russia and
ukraine but also for
the broader security of europe
there is still time there is still time
for vladimir putin to step away from the
brink but there are there is only a
limited amount of time for him to do
that okay just another couple of very
quick thoughts um the met police
yesterday confirming in an
investigations death threats made to kia
stammer following boris johnson's
comments about um jimmy savelle this is
what um keira's dumber said yesterday
just want to get your thoughts on this
the prime minister knew what he was
doing when he
introduced that slur
the other day
but this is not about me
there are threats to too many
politicians
particularly women actually
should the prime minister reconsider and
just say sorry
the prime minister did clarify his
remarks and of course
i deeply regret what happened uh to
kierstama
every politician needs to be able to go
about their job through without fear
that's that's very important but
ultimately it's the perpetrators who
attacked kearstarma who
verbally abused kierstarma who we should
be putting the blame on yeah pm darting
between cobra meetings heading up to
scotland going to the northwest the
northeast is leveling up traveling again
to europe um is he ever going to have
time to fill in this questionnaire for
the police
well he is fully cooperating
with the police inquiry but as you've
rightly said kay there is a very serious
situation at present
that we've been discussing with russia
and ukraine and the prime minister is
fully focused on that he will be
chairing a meeting of cobra
later this morning to make sure that we
are really pursuing the diplomacy that
we are pulling out all the stops on that
at the same time as preparing for the
worst and making sure we are in the best
possible position to respond alongside
our nato allies i wouldn't want to swap
places in your very elegant shoes this
morning uh foreign